all Belarus is a complex issue for us
because on one hand we consider them the
same aggressor as Russia because
Russians troops are using them as a
platform basically they use airports
they use Railways they use uh as places
to shoot missiles our way on the set on
another note there are neighbors and so
far we had no evidence during one year
of war no evidence of any below Russian
soldier Crossing Ukrainian border so
it's very complex for us so we are
watching closely what's what's happening
in the Belarus because we hope that
eventually Democratic Society will win
there lukashenko regime will be out and
we will just set up a normal
neighborhood you know relationship yeah
we had
that would be a leader in Belarus on the
program a couple of days ago this is
what she had to say
I see
eagerness to help us to be with the
buildersense and but I asked for example
to synchronize all the sanctions against
the regime with the European Union to
increase assistance to our media to our
human rights defendant centers to stay
in solidarity with those it's very
important because I uh when I see that
person people feel that they are
forgotten they are abandoned they lose
this energy to continue this fight now
it's on the top but we need the world
attention
so the opposition basically in Belarus
needing a lot more support from the
European Union and and further beyond
that is that is that what you agree with
yeah I agree with this also like over 2
000 Bill Russian volunteers are fighting
on Ukrainian side against Russians which
showing their real real support to
Ukrainian freedom and democracy but it
looks as though
um Russia is planning to put nuclear
weapons yes in Belarus
um what sort of challenges might not
and what will Ukraine do if that happens
well we treat this more like a threat
right now we don't believe that it's
going to be in reality but no one knows
you know we learned during this year
everybody knew that you know everybody
did not believe that Russia will invade
on such a you know large scale but they
did so we all the whole world has to be
prepared I think that if there really
will be serious about it I think we we
are facing a real challenge to have a
second front opened it's about I think
more than thousand kilometers lengths of
the potential front was a Belarus what
would that mean for men a fighting age
in your country I don't know that would
mean a real challenge to get even more
people uh to conscript into to the Army
because like we will need at least eight
more brigades to control this front line
fortunately for us the territory and
terrain there is more like a lot of
swamps so it's very hard to break into
that so if we control roads it will you
know like decrease the vulnerable areas
for us I understand
um the tanks um the the Challenger tanks
that have been promised by the UK I
believe
um going to be on their way very soon
yeah yeah exactly I'd like to actually
to use the moment and thank all the
British people for this you know because
you are trendsetter for anything that we
need first the British kind of breaks
the psychological barrier among all the
partners and then they start giving uh
similar things too because without the
you know British position I think we
will still wait for the Germany to get
the political decision on the tanks you
know on Lee parts and and others and I
think you know like the next step will
be the aviation and I think uh Britain
will also like set a standard you know
and this kind of fighter jets yeah right
you still think that that is going to
happen yes I believe you know like
nobody believed that it's going to
happen with Highmark systems nobody
believed in the tank Coalition I believe
in ship Coalition and jet fighters
fighter jets Coalition as well you know
like it just like takes time
unfortunately you know during that time
too many Ukrainian soldiers dying every
day but I think that eventually uh
International Partners will realize that
it has to be a support uh giving as soon
as possible because you see how they are
um you know increasing Stakes all the
time in this nuclear threats and stuff
like that so we just like have to kick
them out of the country as soon as
possible very quickly when's this all
going to end
no one else you know like we're gonna
fight uh you know as much as
um you know as it takes because like we
cannot really sacrifice half of the
country the territory just because one
crazy guy decided to do so
it's good to see you come back again
soon thank you very much